a familiar scene just hours after Hong
Kong's chief executive announced the
withdrawal of an extradition bill that
sparked violent protests but the
concession failed to appease protesters
on Thursday Carrie Lam faced the media
to explain why it took so long to give
in to the protesters demands and that
she had Beijing's full support
throughout the whole process the central
People's Government took the position
that they understood why we have to do
it they they respected my view and they
supported me all the way since June
violent confrontations between police
and the mostly young protesters have
become an almost daily event against
much opposition the government tried to
push through the bill that would have
allowed suspects in Hong Kong to face
trial in mainland China positive to
address all the other demands okay and
gesture to acquit again if she have done
this you know withdrawal of the view you
know three months earlier the other
issues include voting rights since
Beijing appoints Hong Kong's leader
through an election committee and more
pressing for many in the city
an investigation into police conduct
during the months of protests as people
go about their business here on a rare
day the city is not convulsed with
protests you could be forgiven for
thinking that life in Hong Kong is going
back to normal but there are constant
reminders everywhere that this is a city
on edge Hong Kong operates under one
country two systems model enjoying
freedoms unthinkable in other parts of
China but in recent years there has been
an unprecedented interference from the
central party in the city's affairs many
of the protesters feel the government
puts Beijing's interests ahead of their
needs and they warn the city's autonomy
and their future is at stake we believe
it is an attend
2+8 us but of course it will not work we
have seen through Carolyn's lies we have
seen through the lies of this government
and we will not back down
not even once doubt a clear message that
the end of the extradition bill does not
mean an end to the city's unrest the
Vigo Palin al Jazeera Hong Kong